welcome to our course titled
introduction to epigenetics the
materials for this first lesson will
provide you with the general
introduction to epigenetics or above
genetics an important research area for
molecular biology and important for
analysis of molecular data types left
chip seek my sole physique and
specialized RNA see we hope to make
these lessons informative for beginners
and advanced users by touching on some
important concepts maybe without going
into much detail where possible as a
quick guide we will introduce important
biological and analytical concepts
related to the types of data used to
analyze epigenetic variation we will
also introduce several commonly used
tools for epigenetic data analysis more
in-depth study will be provided in
subsequent lectures and reference
materials included in the discussed
projects and methods historically the
word epigenetics was used to describe
events that could not be explained by
genetic principles Konrad Waddington
that lived between 1905 and 1975 who is
given credit for coining the term
defined epigenetics as the branch of
biology which studies the causal
interaction between genes and their
products which bring the phenotype into
being his understanding of potential
epigenetic changes are shown in these
figures from his publication on the
topic as opposed to his predecessors
Waddington understood the limitations of
possible epigenetic changes and related
the landscape of this potential as a
link between genes and the environment
over the years numerous biological
phenomena some considered bizarre and
inexplicable have been lumped into the
category of epigenetics
these include seemingly unrelated
processes such as para mutation in maize
position effect variation in the fruit
fly Drosophila and imprinting of
specific paternal or maternal loss AI in
mammals
although mysteries abound the field is
uncovering common molecular mech
underlying epigenetic phenomena that
affect human health or understanding of
disease and the fascinating and
heritable traits that are not recorded
in the DNA today we understand
epigenetics as the study of mechanisms
that cause changes in gene expression
but that are not changes in the DNA
sequence these mechanisms include DNA
methylation histone modification
activity of non-coding RNA such as micro
RNAs and the effect of non-coding
repeating regions in the DNA code before
we go into the specifics of epigenetic
variation or regulation let's discuss
the structure of DNA and how it is
organized in eukaryotic cells as you
remember the foundational understanding
about phenotypes is that DNA codes for
genes those genes are transcribed into
RNA which are then translated into
proteins however these processes appear
to be regulated by a variety of
mechanisms that are not directly
recorded in the actual code of DNA in
fact individuals and members of
different species can have similar DNA
like twins or many conserved genes like
humans and monkeys but significant
phenotypic variation can be easily
observed that is the result of
epigenetic changes that are either
established and passed through
generations or acquired and lost
throughout the organisms lifetime the
eukaryotic cell has a nucleus that
contains tightly packaged DNA folded
into structures that we all know as
chromosomes these are packaged together
by the way of chromatin protein
complexes that the DNA is wrapped around
on these images you can see how the DNA
string has more bumps or beads these
visible beads are called histones when
these beads were originally discovered
scientists first confused them with
genes until eventually it was proven
that the string-like structures actually
contained the genetic code histones can
be either grouped together forming lumps
of DNA or as we can see in the picture
on the right relaxed and spread out
the changes in the way DNA is packaged
is used for cell division when whole
chromosomes need to be moved around or
to regulate what code is more or less
accessible for transcription the
regulation of DNA compactness is
regulated in several ways one of these
is DNA methylation site design which is
one of the amino acids can be modified
by a methyl group
ch3 attached by a specialized protein
called DNA methyl transferase in the
first minutes of life when we are
composed of a single cell and this
epigenetic information has been wiped
clean
in the fertilized egg the methyl groups
have been removed and even and every
gene is like all the others through the
process of cell differentiation DNA
methyl transferases add methyl groups to
genes shutting off some in activating
others when a cell divides the
epigenetic information must be
transmitted to each of the new cells a
different DNA methyl transferase dnmt1
adds the proper methyl groups to these
DNA strands as it is replicated the
information is propagated in a tricky
way methyl groups almost always added to
site design bases with these sequences
CG and GC
notice that both strands have a cytosine
so in a methylated region of DNA both
strands will have a methyl group when
the DNA is replicated each of the new
DNA double helix E's will have one old
strand complete with methyl groups and
one strand which is not methylated so
dnmt1 just needs to look for CG base
steps where only one strand has a methyl
group the basic repeating unit of
chromatin is the nucleosome in which
hundred and forty-six base pairs of DNA
wraps around an octamer of core histones
consisting of pairs of h3 h4 h2a and h2b
in terminal tails of histones protrude
out of the nucleosome and are subject to
a variety of post translational
modifications such as acids elation
phosphorylation you
halation and lysine and arginine
methylation a set elation was the first
of these modifications to be linked with
active transcription and subsequently
phosphorylation of histone h3 was found
to cooperate with a situation and
translational activation some histone
methylation events have also been
associated with transcription activation
and others with gene silencing one
important aspect of histones is that
they can be changed to alter how much
packing the DNA is capable of
there are several modifications that
affect how well DNA is packaged the
basic regulation is done via groups of
atoms that are at the ends of histones
these can be of several types and will
have a positive or a negative charge
that either track them together or force
them apart the DNA region that is
wrapped around the histones can be more
or less accessible causing variation in
gene expression histone proteins or
nucleosomes undergo a host of different
post translational modifications
including phosphorylation acetylation
and methylation which have profound
effects on the remodeling of chromatin
histone modifications can function
either individually or combinatorially
to govern such processes as
transcription replication DNA repair and
apoptosis methyl groups of atoms
increased packing an acetal group
decreases packing also phosphoryl group
can be attached to the histones and
cause a decrease in packing these groups
of atoms are attached to various types
of histones at various locations as the
DNA is wrapped around the histones and
can be more or less accessible various
positions of the DNA are affected these
include the promoter region
transcription start sites and the
introns and exons of genes each one of
these elements can have a significant
effect on the level of gene expression
on alternative splicing as well as other
downstream regulation of pathways the
size of the region and its location are
both important it turns out that
different histone modifications are
associated with specific widths
and profiles of Peaks that can be
detected in chip seek data so how can we
study comments and changes and histone
modification chromatin
immunoprecipitation or chip seek uses
antibodies designed to bind to specific
proteins of interest
pío is these can be histones or other
complexes attached to the DNA the
antibodies bind to proteins thus helping
cut out the portions of DNA that we
would like to select for sequencing then
the antibodies and proteins are removed
from DNA and libraries for sequencing
are produced the whole process looks the
following DNA and protein of interests
are selected and antibodies are designed
fragmented DNA help select those areas
that have proteins attached to them
antibodies are then attached to the
proteins of interest and those sections
are selected then the DNA is released
and sequencing libraries are prepared
after sequencing we analyze the data for
Peaks looking for specific patterns that
are associated with different histone
modifications and the openness or
closeness of DNA the major goal of the
chip seek analysis of signal
distribution is to detect genome
fragments that are enriched with
upregulated signals these fragments
could be transcription factor binding
sites chromatin remodeling or genome
transcription events the main
algorithmic challenge here is to detect
accurately short and long upregulated
genome fragments generating a whole
genome landscape for the signal probably
the most discussed issue in chip seek
experiments is the best method to find
true peaks in the data a peak is a site
where multiple reads have mapped and
produced a pileup chip sequencing is
most often performed with single and
reads and chip fragments are sequenced
from their 5 prime ends only this
creates two distinct peaks one in each
strand with the binding site falling in
the middle of these Peaks the distance
from the middle of the
to the binding site is often referred to
as this shift ship si can be used to
study histone modifications and the
regions that are affected by histone
methylation or a situation but the DNA
methylation has to be studied using a
different method called bisulfate
sequencing this method looks for
methylated cytosines across the whole
Gihon a one of the major challenges in
analyzing whole genome bisulfite
sequencing data is related to the
library preparation step cytosines on
both strands of the DNA can be
methylated when the strands are
separated by sulphate conversion changes
the non methylated cytosines to uracil
methyl groups protect the methylated
cytosine so they are not affected during
the subsequent PCR amplification step
uracil that appears from by sulphate
conversion will be transformed into
thymine thus a triple conversion between
amino acids occurs at the analytical
challenge is to accurately map reads to
their original location differentiating
between conversions that happened as a
result of by sulphate conversion of
unmethylated cytosines and thymines
that were a part of the original
sequence since both strands of the DNA
are sequenced their complementarity can
be leveraged to address this challenge
comparing quality of mapping to the
reference genome with potential changes
of site assigns to uracil makes the
analysis of such data computationally
intensive and time-consuming in our next
lecture we will discuss non-coding rnas
and their role in gene expression
regulation and epigenetics